No way,
it's famous for its extreme climates,
have long sunny summer days and long
dark winter nights as well as the
extreme cold,
so famous for their welfare state,
like any other Nordic country,
but perhaps most of all,
they're famous for this smoked salmon
and it's not just us that visual
politic.
You think that it's actually the fishing
industry is one of the most modern and
important in the world.
However,
in the last few years,
the most significant element of the
Norwegian identity has been its
commitment to the environment,
especially its fight against climate
change and there is no better place for
us to see this than in their adoption of
the electric car.
You see Norway,
it has the most developed market of
electric cars in the world in.
You'll find that one of every two cars
sold is either electric or it's a
hybrid,
but it's even more to this because by
20,
25,
which is kind of basically tomorrow,
Norway expects to stop selling gas or
diesel powered cars altogether.
They only want to sell electric and
hybrid cars.
Now,
this might be pretty hard to imagine,
right?
I mean,
it's been a hundred years of combustion
engines and it all seems as if he's
about to come to an end.
Middle East,
Norway,
they're electric car mania.
Well,
it's even reached ships to companies are
currently developing a project called
Tesla over the seas.
It's goal is to launch the first
autonomous ship that's powered by
electric batteries.
The first Yara Berkland,
the formal name of the project.
It's expected to be ready by the end of
2018,
and this might all,
if you're wondering,
well,
what's Norway Secrets?
How on earth they made electric cars
quite so popular?
Is it really all to do about just
concern for the environment?
Yeah,
I mean maybe that is a positive,
but if we're honest,
the majority reason,
well,
it's a little less idealistic.
The key for this electric Colombian,
it's got everything to do with the tax
incentives that the government has
granted in order to support the
industry.
So look,
in Norway,
when you choose to buy a vehicle,
you can actually save an enormous amount
in taxes.
If you choose to go for an electric
vehicle,
for instance,
for one,
you don't pay any VAT and in Norway,
and that's 25 percent right off the bat,
you don't have to pay any registration
fees or any other additional taxes.
All right,
so this all sounds well and good,
but what is the actual results of this
all financial.
So according to a recent study,
you got this car,
the Tesla model s.
Now if this was a regular gas car,
if you included all the taxes and
everything else,
this thing in noise going to set you
back about $140,000,
but thanks to the tax relief of the
Norwegian government,
this is actually around $70,000,
which is 50 percent in savings,
which is pretty amazing.
Right?
And that's not even mentioning the other
advantages.
I mean these costs,
they don't have to pay for any tolls and
they don't have to pay.
Parking meters will say there's another
major advantage because in Norway
electricity it's mostly hydroelectric,
which means well,
it's both cheap and it's clean.
All right?
So as a result of these policies and
some of the policies,
the government expects to reduce total
carbon emissions by 40 percent in the
next few years.
If you consider all of these advantages,
like being able to get a test liver 70
grands ams,
the fact that it has one of the highest
living standards in the world,
you might be thinking right now,
well Norway sounds like a pretty amazing
place,
but taking things back to the
environment for a minute,
the Norwegian constitution,
it even actually protect the
environment.
Consider Article One hundred and 10.
Every person has a right to an
environment that is conducive to health
and to a natural environment who's
productivity and diversity are
maintained.
Natural resources should be managed on
the basis of comprehensive longterm
considerations whereby this right will
be safeguarded for future generations as
well.
Article One hundred and 10 B of Norway's
constitution.
Alright,
so as always in one of these videos,
not everything is sunshine and lollipops
and rainbows.
So noise is this really wealthy country
and they've got this really big welfare
state,
but they do have a small issue or
released a problem that makes green
beast really angry.
And this issue,
it is about the oil production of
Norway.
But now the question really has to
become,
I mean,
how oil dependent is Norway?
Well,
let's have a look at that.
Oil addicts,
we can take a time machine back to the
beginning of the 20th century,
we would find Norway with a really basic
economy.
All they did was fishing,
fishing,
and fishing.
Now,
if we traveled forward in time,
even though things did improve
significantly,
Norway during the 19 sixties,
no way included in the list of the
world's wealthiest countries,
not at all.
In fact,
its per capita income was around half of
Switzerland's,
1960.
The standard of living in Norway was
about 30 or 40 percent lower than in
Sweden or Denmark.
Now the standard of living in Norway is
substantially higher than those who
countries renewal guerard and
economists,
the Norwegian business school in Oslo.
So now the obvious question becomes,
well,
what happens?
In what way?
How did it become one of the richest
countries on earth in so little time
where everything began to change in the
year?
Nineteen 69.
This was the year when the first oil
reserves were found and the as the ad,
well,
it's been a bit of a golden age.
The country became one of the world's
largest oil and natural gas suppliers.
As you can imagine,
that this oil revolution means tons of
money coming in,
money that contributed to building the
Norway that we know today,
today oil and natural gas are the keys
of this country's economy.
In 2016,
for instance,
almost 40 percent of exports and more
than a fifth of investment had its
origin in the oil and gas sector.
And of course I mean governments.
It's getting it's share depending on the
year and the prices of gasoline.
All the income that the government
obtains from this industry route one of
every 41 of every six euros of the
government's total tax collection,
and I want to give them.
He gets a ton of money.
Well,
that usually means an increase in public
spending.
World's most generous welfare state
leaves 20 percent on the Dole.
Yeah,
that's absolutely right.
To a certain extent,
we could say the Norwegian model of a
huge welfare state with public control
of many of the large companies has a lot
to do with oil.
However,
the tumbling all of the pros of this raw
material has led the government to take
an incredibly controversial measure for
the first time in 20 years.
The Norwegian government,
it's granting new exploration licenses
in particular tenure instances of oil
exploration in the Barents Sea,
in the heart of the artist.
Exactly
this,
this movement has made Greenpeace and
other environmental organizations
really,
really angry great days by the way.
They've taken the government to court,
accusing them of violating the Paris
agreements and also,
uh,
violating the Norwegian constitution
itself.
As we just told you a moment ago,
the environment,
it's pretty well protected in Norwegian
law,
but the thing is Norway's green
commitments.
Well,
this is set in limitations knowing has
set out to be a global leader in climate
action,
yet continued expansion of oil and gas
production could eclipse the benefits of
Norway's domestic emission reductions
efforts.
Peter Erickson as senior scientists
within the Stockholm Environment
Institute and well,
the reality is that the world's largest
welfare state,
it's certainly does not come cheap.
We as a country are petro holics.
We depend so much on the income from the
oil.
Just like alcoholics.
We want to stop,
but we don't know how Thomas Nielsen,
editor of the independent parents
observer,
but,
but wait for a minute because it is not
like Norway is like some of those other
countries that also rely on oil.
Absolutely not.
Norway is dependent on oil to a certain
extent,
but it's not even close to how dependent
Venezuela or Saudi Arabia are honest in
Norway things.
They are totally different now.
Although the government does carry a lot
of economic weight.
Norway has tried to be open to business
and they have tried to use this oil
money to fund productive activities and
provide a quality education.
They have also been incredibly committed
to saving
fund of funds
for
a country that has made so much money
with the oil industry.
Norway is very different to what we are
used to the capital city.
It's not overtaken by skyscrapers,
massive malls,
extravagant complexes.
Now,
don't get me wrong,
they have spent a lot of money,
but the key to Norway is that they
haven't wasted it.
The Norwegian government,
they make this really sensible decision.
They decided to save a lot of their oil
money.
They set up a sovereign wealth funds at
to invest the money and buy assets all
around the globe,
and this is the biggest sovereign wealth
fund on Earth.
Not even Saudi Arabia,
not even Kuwait,
have saved so much.
Now consider this.
Norway sovereign wealth fund hits
$1,000,000,000,000.
Yeah,
that's absolutely right.
That's a trillion dollars.
This is a fortunate of around $190,000
per Norwegian citizens.
Instead of wasting this money,
they invested it in companies all around
the world.
This fund is invested money or more than
9,000 companies in 78 countries.
Some of these companies really famous.
Your apple,
Nestle,
Shell alphabet.
That's better known as Google.
Indeed.
We could save that.
The Norwegians,
well,
they even own a part of Youtube and you
know what?
One of their targets is to eventually
replace that oil income with income from
these investments.
I mean these are investments,
they produce profit.
It's what they do and these prophets
have been a return of about five point
seven percent a year,
so if these levels of return will speak
at the same,
Norway would have an average of
$50,000,000,000 in profit,
which is equivalent to about 25 percent
of their public spending starting to
sound pretty good.
Right?
And on top of all of that,
of course there's the income that the
government gets from oil and local
companies,
companies that despite being state
homes,
they do work with market criteria are.
So it's still looking pretty rosy.
I mean you might be thinking right now
that Norway,
what does it have to worry about,
but hold on for just a moment because
the welfare level,
it does seem to have a solid base,
but the government is absolutely
determined to achieve economic
diversification in order to have a more
competitive economy so that they
ultimately get rid of their dependency
on oil.
The reforms.
Nineteen,
27.
The center left party has been the most
popular in general elections,
but in Norway,
absolutely majority's.
They're not really common in 2013,
a coalition of center,
right wing parties like the progress bar
see famous for its radical position on
immigration.
Managed to put Erna Solberg in office.
She is known as the Norwegian version of
Angela Merkel in the recent elections
that happened on the 11th of September
2017.
This coalition,
when it was reelected and the intensive,
this government is to get some distance
from what has become known as the
Norwegian model.
The government,
they want to improve the competitiveness
of the country by reducing taxes,
especially for companies both public and
private,
but at the same time they also intend to
keep developing the oil industry
anyway anyway,
if they are sure about something.
In Norway,
it is the innovation and development are
the best ways to obtain high standards
of living and improve the environment.
So well now it is your turn.
Do you think that Norway,
it should be this example of something
to be followed in the management of
natural resources?
Well,
do let us know your answer in the
comments below as well as in this survey
and do not forget to subscribe to our
channel for brand new videos every
Monday and Thursday button below the
screen.
Now,
click on that.
Also do.
Don't forget to check it off.
Friends at the reconsider media podcast,
they provided the vocals in this episode
that we're not mine,
and as always,
thank you for watching,
so you're still here,
still watching this video.
Maybe you just let it run and you're not
actually there anymore.
Whatever the case,
if you're listening to this,
I think you should go check out my new
channel.
It's called biographics.
It is biographies of notable historic
figures as well as present date people.
Let me give you some examples.
We got the queen of England's Vladimir
Putin,
those just two people on the world,
central square,
Elon musk coming up,
Arnold Schwarzenegger,
we even the first serial killer,
h,
h h homes,
maybe just hah homes.
We look at all sorts of people longer
formed about 20 minutes long diving into
the story of their lives in a similar
style to this.
It's biographics.
If you like this channel,
if you'd like my other stuff,
you're going to like this as well.
Biographics.
That is a link in the description below.
Do go check it out and please do
subscribe.